good morning Hank it's Tuesday March
27th I'm coming to you from NYU Medical
Center where I'll be for at least one
more day Sara was like make sure they
know you're sick I'm sick that's my IV
port but I'm doing okay and I'm doing a
lot better since I watched your video
man did that make my week you know I've
said thank you about thirty-five
thousand times in the last few days you
say thank you every time the the woman
comes in and gives you a new IV you say
thank you when they bring you your food
you say thank you when the Yeti shows up
I like the Yeti you say thank you when
the Yeti spends 12 hours a day here you
say thank you every minute of every day
basically because you're helpless and
you need a lot of help and you're
grateful for that help but it's a very
different thank you when you're saying
thank you to someone for going way above
and beyond the call of duty
he said duty and that's what you guys
did thank you in particular but also all
of the viewers to send in those pictures
of stuff on their head and for me to be
able to learn the exciting spoiler that
Ron Weasley is going to die by a
suffocation in a plastic bag and the
deathly hallows to learn all of the
wonderful things that one can put on
one's head from an ironing board to a
large knee-length boot I don't know what
else to say except thanks nerdfighters
you guys are made of awesome anyway heck
the word on the street is that I should
be getting out fairly soon either
tomorrow or Thursday provided things
continue to move along as they've been
moving along if you look at it it's way
better hmm
look how much look how much more white
there is you're looking up my nose
aren't you you are hopefully I will see
you tomorrow here but you will see me on
Thursday at 88th Street thanks again